of some of the Nationals that benefited
from compensations during cold period of
the year thanks to the support provided
by the government and the European
Union last year just like uh many other
citizens of the Republic of mova I have
benefited from compensations for natural
gas for electricity and for the gas that
was used by our gas stove uh for um
District heating gas and electricity it
helped us in particular to spend this
money for the uh District Heating and we
counted on support from our partners
from the EU and the support came right
in time Europe was with us and this was
obvious there were no compensations
there were if there would have been no
compensations our family would have
spent much
more and thanks to the uh compensations
for heating and
electricity um I could we could uh uh go
through the winter uh successfully and
many benefited from this uh compensation
it was uh difficult for us to pay for
the to pay for our bills but thank you
very much for the comp ation yes we
really hope to have compensations
everything is very expensive and would
be really
great and now ladies and gentlemen I
would like to announce the cermony of
signing the letter of intent to amend
the um agreement uh on strengthening the
statehood and resilience of the Republic
of mova and uh it will be signed by the
minister of uh econ e and digitalization
and for the European Union Hardman the
director general of the uh negotiations
and
extension of the letter of intent
regarding the amendment to the state and
resilience building contract for the
Republic of mova for the Republic of
mova it is signed by Mr ditro Alba
Deputy Prime Minister minister of
Economic Development and digitalization
for the European commission it is signed
by Mr heran kopman director general of
the European commission's director
general for European neighborhood and
enlargement
negotiations
dear president Maya sand dear president
of the European commission Ula feran
dear colleagues um the following we
shall have the Press statements uh on
the occasion of the visit to the
Republic of mova with the president fan
dear president ferland dear Ula I'm
happy to see you in kisho for the second
time this year your visit uh for us is
an important signal of support for the
Republic of mova and for its European
path we had a very good discussion with
Miss president about the situation in
the Republic of mdova and the progress
that the Republic of Moldova has
achieved in its European union accession
and I have reiterated that our country
our team does its best to fulfill all
the
commitments to begin the accession
negotiations as soon as possible I would
like to assure you dear president taking
this opportunity too that our
institutions are fully engaged in this
process and that we are working all of
us day and night to make this wish
possible become reality as soon as
possible I have said this and I would
like to repeat moldova's accession into
the European Union is not only a
political Choice it is the only way to
protect our freedom peace and
democracy yesterday I have presented my
vision on ensuring the security of the
Republic of Moldova and I said that our
willingness to join the European Union U
follows or is based on our wish to
modernize and economically develop the
Republic of mova as well as to safeguard
security energy cyber information
military the security of all our
citizens we are strong and safe not only
when we expect and receive support but
also when we contribute to peace and
security on the European continent
recently the Republic of mova has become
a participating state to the Civil
protection mechanism of the European
Union it is an important step in our
European integration process we are
grateful for the assistance that we have
benefited from in the previous crisis
and now we are prepared not only to to
receive but also to provide support
during uh natural disasters and
crisis in such a way together we'll
build a safer and a stronger Europe and
today with President F derlan we had
discussed the continuous and consistent
support provided by the EU to the
Republic of mova I have expressed our
appreciation for the proposal of the
European commission to increase
assistance for our country within the
frame of the revision of the multiannual
financial framework 2021 2027 we also
appreciate the support package provided
by the European commission to mitigate
the negative impact that we had been
feeling because of the Russia's
aggression against Ukraine our country
becames becomes safer and safer thanks
to European funds from the peace
facility which helps us upgrade the
security sector also I would like to
welcome the activity of the partnership
mission of the European Union with the
Republic of mdova whose mandate actually
focuses on building our capacity to cope
with hybrid
attacks EU accession brings more and
more specific benefits to the citizens
of the Republic of mdova today 60% of
our exports go to the European market
mova is party to the Joint platform of
the EU for purchasing gas which means
that we can access new sources of gas at
competitive prices and in less than
three months from starting January 1st
we shall have cheaper phone
conversations when we travel to the
member states of the European Union I
would like to thank Miss president for
personally engaging in making this
possible speaking about energy I would
like to sincerely thank the European
commission and you personally
for the support provided to the people
of the Republic of mova in particularly
those with fewer revenues that had
benefited from compensations in their
bills in the last two Winters and you
had seen actually in this little video
some of the beneficiaries that Express
their appreciation of the support and
I'm happy to be able to announce that by
the end of this year we shall disperse
another 105 million EUR designated for
uh to for the uh energy vulnerability
reduction fund the support of the
European Union has proved and continues
to prove in these difficult years that
solidarity is actually the basis the
Cornerstone on which the EU has been
built and still operates and this is why
we want so much to become party to this
Union to join this peace and prosperity
shared Prosperity project in which
countries are solidary one with one
another and and contribute to the
promotion of our joint and shared values
and to conclude I would like to
reiterate that on the 21st of May this
year the people of our country and
movans from abroad have expressed
clearly and the the belief that the
future of the Republic of mdova is in
the European Union in spite of the
challenges there is one certain thing
one day not too far away from today we
shall join the big European family and
on this path I'm happy to know that you
we have you dear president Fane
next with us and all of your colleagues
from the European
Union thank you and the floor is offered
to miss FL F please thank you very much
dear Maya Madame
President it is very good to see you
again we saw each other right um at the
European political uh community in
ganada last week and indeed as you said
six months ago you also hosted this very
special Summit of the European political
Community right here in chiaro and you
did it
brilliantly it was natural for us
together here in mova because Europe's
heart beats so strongly here mova has
shown time and again how vibrantly
European it is
and How Deeply committed it is to its EU
accession
path this is what I'm here to talk about
today as you know at the beginning of
November the commission will present its
annual report on
enlargement along with others it will
assess moldova's progress as a candidate
Country and this assessment will then
feed into the crucial discussions at the
December European Council Summit so the
stakes are very
high these discussions will have a
direct impact on your future as an EU
country so allow me to make two points
on the ongoing assessment first you are
making excellent
progress and I'm very impressed to see
moldova's determination to move
forward this is thanks to your lead ERS
ship Maya and to the hard work of the
movan people and we are very grateful
for
that second I encourage you to continue
to actively participate in this
accession process and only you can do it
we have reviewed your progress on the
latest reforms and on the challenges you
are facing and now it's time to be
focused and to double down on every
effort because you can do it mov
has already come such a long way despite
so many obstacles and the Russian threat
to its democracy from pressure on your
energy system to vicious attempts to
undermine your sovereignity through
blackmail hybrid attacks and
disinformation I have said it from the
very beginning the EU solidarity with
Moldova is
unshakable and this is underpinned by
action let me men mention Five Points
first of all we have been providing
unprecedented financial support to mova
1.2 billion EUR since October
2021 and of course more is coming and
I'm happy to say that we will disperse
still this year an additional almost 143
million EUR in budget support and microf
financial
assistance among others indeed this
funding will go to vulnerable households
of mova who must deal with the high
energy prices and we've just seen the
testimonials in the
video second our economic and investment
plan is also fully at work with 900
million euros mobilized so far this
money has been invested in the
competitiveness of moldovan businesses
in better Energy Efficiency meaning
lower energy bills for Citizens and an
infrastructure that brings you closer to
us through for example the trans
European Network for
transport the third point we are working
on the package of concrete support
measures I presented here in chisa back
in
May together we are making Moldova more
resilient against security threats of
all kinds so far moldova's armed forces
have benefited from 87 million EUR worth
of European peace facility support and
we're working on a new envelope of 50
million Euros for
2024 so mova is set to become one of the
main beneficiaries of the peace
facility fourth I'm also pleased that
the EU partnership mission to Moldova is
now fully operational it will be a
crucial Ally in our fight uh against
hybrid and cyber threats we need you on
our side in today's world security of
course also includes energy security and
indeed we have not forgotten how
difficult the last winter has been but
we've Made It by standing together by
being jointly facing the challenges and
overcoming them so this is a big story
of success but it also shows how
important it is to stand by each other
this is why is so important that also
mova now can participate in our joint
gas purchase platform this allows all of
us 27 seven member states with mova with
Ukraine Norway and Serbia to pull our
weight to secure supplies and to
negotiate good
prices and finally on a very practical
note we will start indeed lowering the
roaming charges between the European
Union and mova as of the 1 of
January this was very dear to my heart
it will make it easier to travel and
it's a great way to bring people
together
as they experience um as they experience
traveling through the European Union and
we have found a way to wave the fees for
the EU programs we want you in these
programs it's good to have you here for
example Horizon Europe the excellent
research program but also the Union
Civil protection mechanism we are very
proud that you joined we need you you
are excellent in this field and of
course the connecting Europe facility
dear Maya you have long proven that your
future is in our Union I standing up for
the values we hold dear
democracy freedom and
solidarity most recently you welcomed
your neighbors from Ukraine whom you
sheltered from the war you are playing a
vital role in the success of our
solidarity Lanes bringing much needed
grain in and out of Ukraine and here too
we will invest in your regions so that
they develop to good transport hubs with
modern facilities you have once more
shown that the European Union can really
count on you so well done I'm glad to
have you by my side let's keep up the
good work and we hope to welcome you
soon as a full member of our family
thank you very
much
dear colleagues from the media two
questions for each of the officials
please several questions from Miss
vland dear Madam is the there is a wide
and uh broad consensus among European
leaders on the moldova's accession to
the EU
so
2030 would
be uh would this is a question would
2030 be a real timeline for moldova's
accession and when will mova be ready to
start the
negotiations the translation the
translation was there thank you very
much so um the accession process is a
merits based process that is very
important and mova has proven in the
last months how determined and fast mova
is moving on in reforming the country
and bringing it closer to the European
Union there's no such thing like a fixed
state but it's a merits based process so
those who really work hard can join
earlier and um as I said mova in the
last month it was impressive to see the
progress they have you have
made
so the colleagues will use my M uh
public TV station my question is for
Miss fine how could EU ensure that
moldova's path would not be detoured by
Russia especially in the eve of
winter I think um during the last winter
we have proven that by standing together
facing the challenges we had a massive
blackmail by Russia cutting our natural
gas supply and cutting your natural gas
supplies this triggered a major energy
crisis we should not forget that last
year in summer the prices were 10 times
higher than they are today today they
are back to pre-war level but we made it
by standing together we showed a lot of
solidarity we work very hard to
diversify away from Ria friends stepped
in and helped us like for example Norway
we invested massively in renewable
energy so that last year the European
Union for the first time produced more
electricity from Sun and wind than from
gas but most importantly is the
solidarity and the standing Together
made it possible that we went through
this crisis successful and therefore the
answer is to show what democracy can
deliver to show to people what
freedom and solidarity the True Values
of the European Union can unleash and
the forces they can develop is important
to prove to people that the better way
to choose and therefore I'm very
confident that people have choices that
they can
makeala TV8 Miss smile s uh I would like
to know how many out of those nine
conditionalities have been achieved so
far which ones are still not fulfilled
and if it would be real to fulfill them
by the end of this year to start the
accession
negotiations I think we have to be
patient and wait for the European
commission report in November and see a
an objective assessment of our efforts
otherwise um we know which are the areas
that we have to keep up doing the work
and first of all these efforts refer to
the reform of the justice fight against
corruption and our efforts to De
oligarch eyesee or eliminate remove the
vulnerabilities which have led in the
past to to our state becoming captured
by vested interests and we are engaged
in this process in spite of the
impediments and in spite of the
resistance that we see every day from
people that have ill intentions in the
system we continue to work till the
report of November we will continue
working after the report assessment
report in November and we appreciate
what the president has said and we have
heard an appreciation of our effort we
are however determined to do everything
we have to on time so that we can
continue you were confidently on the
path that we had Chosen and I'd like to
reiterate it is not only a political
Choice a political decision this is the
only option uh when we can consolidate
and keep our democracy thank you the
event is over please a joint
photo
[Music]